hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Veronica who
wrote in asking about buying domain
names and does it matter who she buys it
from so sure oh it ain't saying I learn
for you that's important to get Canadian
hosting for cleaning businesses thanks
but I'm not sure doesn't mean that I
should register a new domain name also
the cleaning company or does it not
matter in this case just wanted to ask
this quick question thanks hope is all
well miss your amazing SEO talk so I
used to do a session in Toronto work for
SEO helping some companies Veronica came
out a lot so thank you for the question
of Veronica so to answer your question
there's three things you can do if you
are not an American company so if you're
a Canadian company or elsewhere and you
want to rank in your local country so I
guess this would also help for Americans
who are trying to rank in America as
well so the first thing you do is your
hosting so where your hosting companies
can impact your rankings and it's not
necessarily where the company is its
where the servers are so you may have
some companies in Canada that are just
sales reps and the actual servers are
somewhere in Texas or Chicago or
wherever so you want to make sure that
the server that you're going to be
hosted on will be in Canada if you want
to improve your Canadian rankings so a
quick way to tell I use a chrome plugin
that's here that you can see that for
any website it'll show you where the
server is so for me from Karen column in
Chicago Illinois now I target North
American audience so I don't care if I'm
in US or Canada so that's why my website
is hosted in us if you want it really
like Canadian ranking then you'd want to
try to get that switch to a
canadian-based server if you can
so that's first off the next thing you
can do is buy odot see a domain name so
an example is my wife's company trying
to dance salsa that CH teaches salsa
classes here in Toronto and even though
her website is actually in the United
States because she has a dot see a name
that carries a lot of weight with google
for and the other search engines for
ranking locally in your countries so
this is a great option if you have the
dot CA now this limits you if you are
trying to go to an international market
and they see that you don't have the
dot-com then it's harder to get approval
it's harder to get rankings people are
less likely to want to do business with
you but if you are at a local business
and you target a certain country
geographic area then having the local
extension can really help you the last
thing you can do you know if you already
bought your domain name and you don't
want to move over to another server
another thing you do is go to your
webmaster tools and on your google
webmaster tools and this is free for
everybody you can go to site
configuration and then go down to
settings and you can click a geographic
target so i haven't done this for my
website because i don't only want to
target users in one country but if you
were specifically only looking to target
users in canada you can go target users
and then you know go to canada up on the
list and then click Save and then Google
would know that you're trying to target
users in Canada and you'd show up higher
in Canada but worse everywhere else so
for i'm gonna not even not click that
off because i don't want to show up
worse at other countries so for culture
it for a business like my wife's which
is only selling to people really in the
Toronto area Toronto Canada then that
would be helpful for her so she could
say I only care about my rankings in
Canada and not about you know
international rankings are u.s. rankings
for a website like mine I wouldn't want
that to happen because I'm in supporting
the rank everywhere so Veronica I hope
that helps those three different ways
you can use so if you really have the
domain IAM doesn't necessarily mean you
need to buy a new one you could just
switch the hosting or also go to your
webmaster tools and say that you want to
focus on canada
if you guys liked the video please give
it a thumbs up and it also love to hear
what you have to say if you want to
comment under the video your your thumbs
up and your comments keep it going to
love seeing those coming in every day so
that looks really great so thank you and
stay tuned for next episode
you